in the last video we got some practice
adding what we could consider smaller
numbers for example if we added three
plus two we could imagine that if maybe
I had three lemons 1 2 3 and if I were
to add to those 3 lemons maybe 2 lime is
it lime or limes let's justwell the two
green lemons or 2 2 more tart pieces of
fruit how many how much tart sour fruit
do I have now well we learned in the
last video we have one two three four
five pieces of fruit so three plus two
is equal to five and we also saw that
that's the exact same thing as if we add
two plus three and I think that makes
sense because this is the same thing as
starting with maybe you have two lemons
and you add three lime to it you're
still going to end up with five pieces
of fruit one two three four five just
like that so it doesn't matter what
order you add in you're still going to
get five and this is this way of
thinking about addition iView is the
counting way of thinking about addition
the other thing we saw in the last video
is a number line version and they're
essentially the same thing so we could
draw a line and all a number line is it
lists all of the numbers in order it
lists all the numbers and you can
actually go as high as you need to go
you could go up to a million gazillion
trillion we won't do that I wouldn't
have space or time in this video to do
it and you actually can go as low as
possible we'll start at zero assuming
and in future videos I'll tell you about
numbers smaller than zero and maybe you
can think about what that might mean
tonight but let's start at zero and zero
means nothing if I have zero lemons if I
have zero lemons it means I have no
lemons so 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
let's go pretty high 12 that way I can
reuse the number line 13 14 I could keep
on going but maybe 14 will be enough for
this video but let's use a number line
for these addition problems up here so
in the last video just as a bit of
review
you you can view three plus two is
starting at three and then adding two to
it or going to greater than three and
just going greater or adding on the
number line is just moving to the right
or moving up by two so let's move up by
two I'll do that in I'll do that in this
orange color so let's move go up by two
so we started at three we go up by one
and then we go up by two or we're
jumping and we end up at five which is
exactly what we got before if we have
three lemons we add one lemon we have
four lemons we add another lemon we have
five lemons or a lime or tart pieces of
fruit whatever you might want to say and
when you look at this version of it
where you switch to the order we started
it to and we're adding three objects to
it in this case they were lemons or
limes so we're going to add 3 to it 1 2
3 and just like we expected we got the
same thing we got five again now what I
want to do in this video and hopefully
this was just a bit of review is I want
to tackle harder problems I want to
tackle slightly larger numbers and then
in the next video and in this video I
want to give you practice dealing with
the slightly larger numbers and the next
video were going to dig a little deeper
and think about what numbers even mean
but let's just get some practice
understanding how do you actually do the
addition problems with larger numbers so
let's let me write it a nice soothing
purple color let's say I wanted to add
let's say I wanted to add nine plus
three nine plus three well there's a
couple of ways we could do it we could
draw circles again we could say let's
see I have maybe I'll draw stars one two
three fourth my stars are degrading five
six seven eight nine that's nine stars
and then I add three stars to it so I
add one two three stars and then if you
were to count the total number of stars
you would say let me do that in a
different color one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
I now have twelve stars so you'd say
that nine
plus 3 is equal to 12 is equal to 12 if
you looked at the number line if you
looked at the number line you're
starting at 9 maybe you have 9 stars and
you add one star 2 star 3 stars to that
and you end up with 12 stars which is
the exact answer we got before so you
can do you can do the same process when
you start adding larger numbers and even
though that now and I want you to notice
the difference now is our answer has two
digits in it it will talk more about
digits in a future video but all the
digit is is a numeral right it has a 1
and a 2 that's what 12 is I won't button
I won't dig too deep into that right now
I think you're pretty familiar with the
number 12 but what I want to do is now
what happens when you start adding more
when you start adding two-digit numbers
like this for example if I were to add
if I were to add if I were to add 27
plus plus let's say I don't know plus 15
now if you had a lot of time on your
hands and you didn't care about how
people judged you you could draw out 27
circles and then draw out another 15
circles and then count the total number
of circles you had and that would give
you an answer or you could draw a number
line you could draw a number line that
went all the way to you know whatever 27
plus 15 is so it's going to be this
really really large number but that
would take you forever so what I'm going
to do is show you a way to do this type
of problem where you really just have to
know your addition almost have it
memorized or at least if you don't have
it memorized be able to do something
like this for relatively small numbers
and by doing it for the relatively small
numbers you can do the harder problems
like this so what you do this is the fun
part you add so let's scale and I'll
talk more about what this means in the
future you look at each of the digits so
we call this place the rightmost place
we call that the ones place we call that
the ones place now why do we call that
the ones place because 27 is 20 and 7
ones
is 20 plus seven it's twenty plus seven
ones you could view it as it's 20 plus
seven pennies and this place right here
is called the tens place now why is it
called the tens place I mean there's a
two right there you know it's the place
is called the tens place so putting in a
two here means two tens right the number
20 that's two tens if I have one dime
and you give me another dime I now have
two dimes and that's 20 cents so that's
what the tenths place is and I don't
want to confuse you I just want to show
you how to do these problems right now
well dig a little bit deeper in future
videos but I just want to give you that
idea but the way to do these problems is
you just look at the numbers in the ones
place and add those up first so you say
okay I'm not going to worry about this
whole thing right now let me just add
the 7 and the 5 so I'm going to add the
7 and the 5 and if you don't know what
they did that is hopefully you'll be
able to do that in your head fairly
shortly you could look at the number
line let's look at the number line here
so if you add 7 if you take 7 and you
add 5 to it 1 2 3 4 5 we end up at 12 or
you if you started at 5 and added 7
you'd also end up at 12 so let's say
write that down we know that 7 plus 5 is
equal to 12 so what we do is we say 7
plus 5 is equal to an odd this is a new
thing this is going to you might be a
little bit of a mystery magical thing
for you right now and in future videos
I'll explain to you why this works we
write we want to write the 12 7 plus 5
is 12 but we just write the 2 here and
we carry the one write 12 1 2 well we
wrote the 2 there but we put the one up
here right and the reason I'll give you
a simple reason for doing that right now
I'll give you a better reason in the
future is that you only want you only
had space to put one digit here and 12
is a two-digit number so we have to
think of some other place to put that
one if you really want to think about it
even more 12 is the same thing as 10
plus 2 right that's the same thing as 12
so if we say 7 plus 5 that's the same
thing
as 12 which is the same thing as two
ones right - ones two pennies plus one
dime plus 1/10 plus one dime so we put
that one dime in the tens place so we
really just said seven plus five is one
ten plus two ones or one dime plus two
pennies if that confuses you just write
just write or say well I just write the
ones digit of the two there and I carry
the one and then you do the exact same
thing in the tens place you had the one
plus the two plus the one so 1 plus 2
let's do that on the number line this is
fun so let's see 1 plus 2 let's start
let me do it in a vibrant color we do it
in this magenta so we started 1 we're
going to add 2 to it right 1 plus 2 we
take that 1 from our from our 12 1 plus
2 so you go up 1 2 you end up at 3 then
you're going to add up another one
so you're add another one so you're
going to add up end up at 4 so you ended
up at 42 and this was pretty neat right
because we didn't have to draw a number
line all the way to 42 and we didn't
have to draw 42 objects just by knowing
what 7 plus 5 was and by knowing but
what 1 plus 2 plus 1 was we were able to
figure out that 27 + 15 is 42 let's do
another example maybe I'll do a little
bit of a simpler example let's say I had
let's say I had 78 78 plus 3 we do the
exact same thing before we just look at
the ones place only so we look at 8 plus
3
8 plus 3 what's 8 plus 3 hopefully we
can do that in our heads at this point
let's just think about 8 plus 1/8 plus 1
is equal to 9 8 plus 2 is equal to 10 8
plus 3 is going to be equal to 11 you
could do that on the number line if it
makes it easier to visualize for you so
8 plus 3 is equal to 11 so what we do
here it says 8 plus 3 is equal to 11 put
this one right here put that there and
carry the other one because 11 is 110
one dime plus one penny that's 11 and
then we add the tens place one dime plus
7 dimes
is equal to eight dimes so 78 plus three
is equal to 81 and now there's one thing
I want to show you you don't always have
to carry numbers like that only if the
answer to one of these has more than one
digit in it right 11 is a two-digit
number
so for example if I have 56 plus 2 here
I could just say 6 plus 2 is 8 right
hopefully we're getting good practice at
this so 6 plus 2 is 8 and then I don't
have anything to add this 5 to so I just
bring the 5 down here so 56 plus 2 is 58
just like that and this is one you
actually could have drawn on the number
line it wouldn't have been too hard so
if you were to draw the number line like
that you know zero would be way off to
the left someplace but let's say add 50
you know they could have 49 you can keep
going to the left but you have 51 52
actually let me start a little higher
than that because I'm going to run out
of space let me start it maybe 55 56 57
58 59 and I could go in both directions
keep going but if we start at 56 right
then we add two we go up one we go up
two we end up at 58 so just like that
we're able to do that problem I'll see
in the next video